et que la majorité des gens
soutiennent toujours la Russie,
mais je crois aussi qu'une majorité de
gens n'ont pas un accès adéquat à des
informations objectives.
[Musique]
nous devons faire quelque chose parce que comme
en Chine, il n'y a pas de médias officiels
ni de représentant des médias officiels ukrainiens
et  c'est pourquoi l'Ukraine s'est formée après
peut-être
quatre
quatre cinq jours après avoir
commencé à traduire son site Web en
chinois parce que nous comprenons que nous
perdons cette bataille médiatique,
attendez une seconde, le site Web continue
[Musique]
ok, nous nous battons pour la liberté, nous nous
battons pour eux.
les nouvelles pour lesquelles nous nous battons pour la
vérité
parce que c'est ce qui est important,
nous voulons
que le peuple ukrainien soit ici,
vous